hello everyone I hope everyone's doing
fine got another lecture today hopefully
our sound is good today let us pray
let's see what my son says does the
sound come out right so far so good okay
so today we cross our fingers that
nothing happens yesterday we think we
had a call on the phone and came to the
same line I think that's what gave us
the lousy background noise there that we
had anyways we were dealing with science
what is rational science and that came
about because there was this individual
who answered a letter there's another
one who also wrote to me asking me to
look at his proposal his paper and so
you know I kind of put them both
together because there are a lot of
misconceptions as to what science is and
part of that has to do with as I see it
you know there's an extrapolation if I
define science as I do as rational
explanations and here I have it I think
I think it's this one yeah science
rational explanations I think that's
straightforward you don't need to go to
college to understand all that at least
at first instance but there's a lot
involved there and there's two words
rational and explanations and those two
words absolutely need to be defined you
cannot proceed without them and let me
tell you why we had all kinds of problem
with this word exclamation let alone
rational but the word explanation I've
had all kinds of problems with people
confused descriptions with explanations
and so whether you agree with my
definition or not all I'm saying is we
absolutely need to define what an
explanation is and right now we have a
problem with that because most people
have a different notion of what an
explanation is or they have no notion
whatsoever and they never thought about
nay always thought that descriptions are
explanations let me tell you why I
wanted
distinguish that in first instance
mathematics can only describe
mathematics has no power to explain
absolutely anything and so if
mathematics can only describe there has
to be a difference between a description
and explanation for the purposes of
physics okay and I think that's the most
important point you should keep in mind
mathematics can only describe and I've
got a couple references there one is
this fellow
Donald Semenuk he says science referring
to mathematical physics science doesn't
explain science describes that's what he
says so he apparently seems to know that
there's some kind of difference there
whether he he hasn't specified what he
means by that but he uses these two
words okay and he uses them distinctly
he kind of recognizes that there's a
difference between them and then the
other fellow is keep forgetting his name
he's the guy from Houston Texas he's a
Nobel Prize winner and I can't remember
his name
Oh Stephen Weinberg Steven Weinberg he's
he says in a video that I've got over
there in which he says you know that he
clarifies to his interviewer that you
know you know we we don't really explain
what we do is describe you know they
describe in other mathematical physics
only describes it doesn't explain and I
guess that relates to people who try to
come forward to a mathematician and ask
him why questions and mathematicians
feel you know very uneasy with like
question what they do is simply dismiss
that as non science he said well that's
philosophy why then what they're
interested is in measurement and I guess
you could call it how how something
behaves as to rather than as what caused
it to behave that way or what is the
mechanism they're not interested in that
part they're only interested in
describing mathematically and that's all
mathematic can do described so if we're
gonna remove mathematics from physics if
we're gonna separate those two and say
look math does not really do physics
because math only describes in physics
explains then we must
absolutely define these terms
unambiguously rigorously does it matter
what we call science if you just want to
answer someone's question yeah I guess
you could I mean the only purpose of
inventing the word science is to put
everything under a single umbrella like
you know what do we call the whole bunch
the whole shebang but we just call it
science yeah it's a big word that's all
it is
I mean I'm not sure we need to do that
you're right all we need to do you know
you're on an island and your marooned
with another fellow and you don't have
to categorize yeah you don't can't have
to categorize it for him you don't do
stamp collecting on the island he just
says you know why did that bird fly well
and so you go out there and explain you
flaps its wings and etc you know you
answer the specific question that he
asked specially if the plane flew by and
you didn't wave it down
you just don't we're ruining another 10
years you know that's the point you
don't really need to categorize all
these things
yeah into science and philosophy or
what's religion it's really just for
maybe organizing it I think what it does
it makes it more helps you focus it it
kind of separates black from white to
kind of thing you know you put science
here you put religion here so what a
science well you want to distinguish
between physics and philosophy over here
what do you want to do well you want to
distinguish between supernatural
explanations versus irrational
explanations that's sort of the thing
it's just categorizing so that people
can see it in terms of black and white
and I like black and white not because
of many racism by the way I like black
and white because it you know it helps
the mind people see okay I see what this
guy's saying I see what that guy saying
they have a contrast if it's all blurry
if it's all gray in there then that's
where people run into trouble there they
and and that's what happens with these
definitions of explanation versus the
description there's a lot of gray in
there in between and you know and people
in that fuzzy
is a serious problem for people
understanding why you're saying what
you're saying what you're trying to you
know do in in the realm of science of
physics I think it's especially
prevalent in debates when you do people
having a debate it's very important to
have these rules of a debate kind of in
the background or that everybody knows
the rules of engagement yeah it's kind
of the rules even where if you have this
table of what science and what's
philosophy and what's religion and once
other yeah then if we're having if we're
gonna have for example have a scientific
debate on physics right what is light
for example how does magnetism work yeah
that's a debate like I don't think those
that's such a thing exist because
everyone seems to be on the same page of
these things but assuming we had a
debate and it's really important to have
these guidelines that way if anyone says
anything that falls under philosophy or
religion then you can be like hey do we
have the referee pull up the yellow card
the red card you're not within the
warnings of our of our discussion of
ours yeah yeah so you only derail the
debate with these I mean if you're just
adding poetry for poetry saying that
might be a different issue halfway
through you say mother nature or
whatever well we really just mean like
the collective workings of the universe
I have no problem closing arguments
including poet it's not only closing
argument so you might say that halfway
in yeah but it's understood that it's
kind of like shorthand poetry for what
you really mean in a different sense
maybe that also shouldn't be allowed
that's a different discussion it's like
they follow you yeah but but I think
that's why it's important to have rigid
definitions for physics and philosophy
science in general and religion yes if
we have through that criteria where in
everything that you can say or postulate
could fall into then we can always
categorize what if you're if you are
saying is really
if what you're saying is philosophy if
what you're saying is yeah that we
intelligent dog yeah we can talk within
the same realm if we want to talk
philosophy it's better to just talk to
Lhasa fee we want to talk physics it's
better just to talk physics yeah yeah we
want to talk religion well then yeah and
yeah and that's I think the bottom line
the bottom line is to put it in black
and whites or the way you know on and
off yes or no so that people can see a
clear difference between one side and
the other otherwise if you got a lot of
grey in there you know that that create
serious problems for understanding and
that's when people ask a lot of
questions and so yeah science is
rational explanations and we need to
define them what a rational first let me
DC go with explanation especially I want
to differentiate it from what what the
description is right let's see what are
these two this he was I think it's this
one no it's the other one so these are
my definitions for what a description is
and what an explanation is now included
another word which I call narrative for
narration and that's the description is
a listing of properties of an object and
again these keep in mind these
definitions are for the purposes of
science okay so you know what we're
doing here is just strictly for physics
science we don't care about ordinary
speech ordinary speech let's go to the
ordinary dictionary here these are
definitions I'm proposing for science in
science we are used adjectives to
describe objects okay so you you're
gonna describe a chair you say it's
brown it's got four legs all that is a
description okay you haven't explained
anything you haven't done anything with
the chair all you're doing is describing
the chair we only use it to describe
objects can we describe concepts I say
we define concepts and describe objects
and I'm
sure there's gonna be a big debate on
that one but but that's just a that's
just a gut feeling right now I'm just
throwing it in there okay let's go with
explanation I've got several here for
explanation and again this is a little
bit of brainstorming it's just my notion
they all kind of relate to the same
thing but their focus from different
angles kind of the causes physics or
reasons underlying a phenomenon the
prosecutors version of how or why
consummate event happened the mechanism
underlying a phenomenon of physics to
theorize and I've included another one
which is you know it's a you know what
is a mechanism it's essentially a movie
of the objects in motion of how it
happened you know in detail so you know
you want to see show how a car runs you
know how it works well you would show
you know gas coming from the tank going
through to the motor doing its thing
until the wheels move you would show
part by part so that the person can
watch the movie and say okay I
understand the mechanism there is no
belief involved it's only understanding
do you understand the mechanism I just
put on the screen that's all it is
that's what I'm seeing an explanation is
it's an objective account of how
something happened or what happened but
not what happened in the sense of you
know the magician kept the lady in half
no it's how he did the trick okay that's
important to keep in mind we use adverse
to qualifier characterized motion and
then I have included a narrative or
narration and that's an objective
typically chronological listing of
events as they happen according to the
witness okay so this so it's just you
know the the famous line cop line says
it's just the facts ma'am just the facts
what happened you know and you just say
well you know this car ran into that one
and he crashed something like that yeah
it's just you haven't explained anything
all you did was say this what I saw or
this is what happened according to me to
my memory whatever and that's it that's
that's where it should stop now the
explanation is what follows after that
you say let me tell you how it happened
you
engine failed now that's a theory now of
why that car ran into the other one now
you're providing a mechanism of what
happened there and that's the
explanation the description in this case
there narration because we're saying
that the scripts is just to describe
objects a narration or narrative is just
when you tell a story objectively this
is what happened you know Joey went to
the river and he caught a fish that's it
it's just you know bam bam bam bam step
1 step 2 step 3 you usually
chronologically not necessarily but
typically chronologically and that's
that's what I'm proposing for science
I'm saying science has to distinguish
between these three terms and what
mathematics does it doesn't do
descriptions really under these
definitions right or explanation
mathematics only do does narratives and
it does it in using quantitative symbols
in other words uses variables equations
numbers that's what they use to describe
will court describe but it's really a
narrative why because all all of
mathematics all of mathematics is
dynamic every equation is a dynamic
thing in other words it creates a single
point on the chart but then you have to
replace the variables in the equation to
get more points then you tie all these
points together and now you have a trend
and so that trend is is motion of
something it's something happening okay
so it's not like you you you get a value
you're like a ratio pie and you get a
number yeah but what did you do you what
you did was you took you took your
you're measuring chord or your you know
your what is it called the measuring not
stick the flexible the measuring tape
and you put it around the circle now you
took the measuring tape spread around
the diameter and you performed an
operation but the two things that you
measured those are dynamic you measure
something that put the ratio in there so
all of mathematics
all of it is dynamic it doesn't deal
with static concepts at all it doesn't
do my son criticized me yesterday there
are no static casa
okay fine yeah we actually go further
nothing about narrative uh-huh perhaps I
have thought about it but perhaps on
concepts our narratives concepts static
description is his is a description and
the description the involves motion is a
narrative and yesterday I said that all
concepts involve motion yeah you saw I
did again yeah I don't agree with that
as I said okay so I mean by my
association I stand I guess all concepts
are actually narratives you're narrating
a relationship between two objects it is
a relationship between two object but we
have to distinguish the the concept from
how we arrived at the concept in other
words put the word Direction okay
directions far as I'm concerned is a
static concept why do we have two
objects do we have someone performing a
relationship between our relation
between them yes but that's how we
determined or how we come to grips with
the notion of direction that's different
than the standalone notion of direction
itself without the observer there's no
such thing there's no such thing as a
standalone well yeah right right but I'm
saying we have to we we we can't get rid
of the word static that's about
everything I'm saying that you know well
I'm saying that we have two categories
we're gonna put static over here on the
left side and we put dynamic on the
right side right and if you say running
I got a distinguished running from
location for example or well because
again one is where do you get confused
or quiz oh I get computer where does
someone get confused if they don't
categorize a concept as static or in
motion well no is there any real I'm not
I look at it from a different point
I'm saying you know these static concept
what I call static concepts involve a
cross-section of time you could say or a
motion in the universe you know there is
one slice of the universal movie just
one slice loaf of bread the block
universe right okay so we take one slice
only and yeah if you take all the slices
and you put them in a row and you make a
movie of them then you have motion but
if you take just one slice you have
location and what is location is there
anything moving within that frame of the
film no nothing is moving and in that
sense I'm saying that even though the
observer the observer watching the movie
right you're watching the movie and now
you just watch that one you know for an
eternity you just stare at one frame at
one picture right you have just the Mona
Lisa it's not movie she's not smiling
she's just got a you know some kind of
weird thing in her mouth right so so
nothing is moving in the picture in
location means that there's a distance
between all these objects and and
they're just static they're they're just
staring at you you are making a
comparison you are dynamically analyzing
the situation yes no doubt no concept
exists without a relation being
established by a conscious observer but
that's different than what's in the
frame the frame itself has nothing
moving with respect to each other and
that's where I put words such as
standing as location as Direction it's
it's just one frame in the film in a
universal in movies that's my notion of
it whether we need that or not I don't
know I'm just categorizing it down you
know okay maybe we don't need it like
you said you maybe baloney but I'm
trying to distinguish the fact that
mathematics doesn't deal with standing
mathematics doesn't deal with exists all
these static concepts as I call them
mathematics doesn't deal with direction
mathematics doesn't deal with dimension
the true dimension of physics
mathematics deals with number lines you
know a little dotted line with an arrow
at the end are the dotted lines and the
arrows pointing
in a direction no it's just it's just
the the dotted line and the arrow mean
that numbers are increasing it doesn't
say that anything is moving they're
saying the numbers are they're counting
the size of the Sun yeah but see they
don't use lasers yeah but yeah but they
don't use length width and height
because immediately as soon as they use
length width and height and call it
three-dimensional they even say three
times the first thing they do is the
site numbers they say well the width is
one meter
what do you mean the width is 1 meter
width has no meters width is with love
is like saying that again we have two
separate physics from mathematics okay
once again physics three dimensional
what do you mean by three dead men so it
means that you got length width and
height they're qualitative notions one
is one stick is 90 degrees to the other
you know 90 I I used a word 90 but
really what we're saying is they're
perpendicular okay it's yeah yeah it's
orthogonal okay so so that's all that's
only a concept the qualitative concept
mathematics does something different
says oh we have really coordinates and
I'm gonna draw so many inches so many
meters something whatever yards from
this point oh yeah to the - to where the
arrow ends and there's six six units or
whatever right so we have six units here
and we have five units here and we have
maybe four here and now you have a
location what do they do you use the
Cartesian coordinates to locate
something you know and that really that
is not the notion of physics of
qualitative you know perpendicularity
that's my point okay you know check the
sound I just saw a little glitch there
you know I don't know if yeah I'm a
little jittery about that sound there's
no meters that that needs to be sent ten
times okay Ted time okay here goes the
first one we passed no meters because we
were so ingrained that the whole point
of lake foot than height is to discern
the meters of something and that's all
point of voice left with an item and I
can talk about the meters what is the
wrong place
about the actual value of meters they
were like like if I want to sell my
computer on eBay I not just put it has
hopefully maybe it only has legs and
wizard or you know then you get a piece
of paper in the mail my only has
lengthened with you not every case about
the numbers after the fact yeah
everything has like those in haiku cares
with the numbers okay because we're used
to numbers were used to putting dollar
sign we're used to putting you know that
used way whole point is no no no it's
the only point no no no no and that's
why I want to clarify that our we were
trained to put numbers everywhere and
you know we do it every day you know
bank accounts whatever we do with
numbers and someone has well how long is
the curtain we don't say well it has
length yeah no we don't say it's like
that's taken for granted no how long is
the curtain or how wide is it or
whatever you know that's how we talk and
so we're so used to that with that we
don't realize that physics doesn't deal
with that this it doesn't care how long
a curtain is or how wide it is
physics doesn't care how long you ran it
doesn't answer any question of fizzy it
doesn't explain anything
we don't need time we don't need length
we don't need weight to explain things
maybe in something I don't know remote
case we might need weight okay maybe
it's possible but I mean to explain
something you explain in qualitative we
don't need to know how much the rock
weighed to show why it broke the glass
we just say look this is the mechanism
mechanism through the rock through the
window broke the window and that's where
the glass is on the floor we don't need
we don't need to know how much the rock
weight yeah of course of course my point
if my point is the following in order to
understand the mechanism where the glass
is I mean the glasses you can say well
if I threw a pebble would break
the window that's not the point the
point is we're trying to get explain a
consummated 'back why the glasses on the
floor we say I don't need to tell you
we'll Darach wait a hundred pounds you
don't need to know that all you need to
know you know all you need to know is
that you know the mechanism the
mechanism is rock hit the glass and and
the glasses on the floor well that's
physics that's the point the point is we
don't use math and physics and not at
all or in science but I think just I
mean physics I equated a very often to a
detective right detective sometimes need
to know the actual weight of a person or
you know for what numbers because
they'll be like okay to do this action
you would you would need a weight of
this much like you know a fact we're
only factors you're talking about the
future I'm talking about the past no no
but the truth is that's a consummate an
event they go only if they're trying to
catch the culprit only a fat person
could have done this so it's not her
yeah but see see you haven't explained
the mechanism the mechanism is the guy
hit him with a stone or stabbed him to
death that's the mechanism you don't
need to know how fast the arm went how
much the knife way you don't need that
data to understand the mechanism I'm
talking about mega physics deals with
mechanism with qualitative only let's
take let's take the pain in the well
yeah someone pulls on the rope
yeah so you got a pulley
now that pulls on the rope and the water
and the pail with the water comes up
okay is there any feasible scenario
where you would need the numbers for the
exact sizes because it seems like it's
taken for granted in that case the sizes
of the pails it might just get give you
that but then I tell you oh by the way
the pale is actually a billion meters
now you go okay wait how did he pull it
up you didn't have the strength to do
that so then it's not important okay
hold it hold it yeah let's make let's
address that issue
yeah that's an important issue we
address that in a hypothesis stage in
the assumption you begin with
assumptions then you go with a theory
you don't go with a theory and then say
oh by the way
it's a billion pounds my point my point
is the billion pounds is relevant in the
assumptions yeah you can put in the
assumption what I'm saying the Saints is
theory science is not that assumptions
science is rational explanations what is
an expansion that's what I'm proposing
yeah I know so is the conclusion don't
you see you do need you could need the
numbers in the assumptions means they're
relevant yeah I guess my point in some
cases you I guess it is but for example
for example let me give you a for
instance and again you know it's maybe
in line of the example he gave gravity
you know I let go to the pen so do I
need to know it falls at 9.8 m/s^2
at that rate at that acceleration in
order to explain the mechanism no I can
just say look imagine that all these
atoms have formed the pen are tied to
the earth and then as it falls you know
there are more ropes independent ropes
participate in the thing falls faster
that's all I can say faster I don't need
to say or it falls at 9.8 meters per
second square I do not need that number
not to explain the mechanism and that's
my point
and let me give you another example that
I don't want to lose and that's that you
know these people and then it goes back
to the length width and height these
people end up saying that space listen
to what they say that space is
3-dimensional that space has length
width and height they get to that
because they you know and in fact that's
a category they say look there's point
there's line there's plane and there's
space no that it's not space it's called
solid not space but they call it space
and they say a three dimensional so so
we end up with this in Congress notion
which the nothingness which has
dimensions and not the somethingness
so you know you figure that out because
they're interested in
distances between objects right and this
is the problem also that they can't
distinguish between distance and length
length is what the table has distances
worth between two tables but they say it
is very important in physics not in math
but it is in physics because we're not
talking about you know the distance of
the table you know what we're saying is
the length of the table is such-and-such
that's the correct word what do we mean
by length were imagining continuous
matter whatever you think of it you know
obviously is made out of atoms obviously
there's interstitial space in there
somewhere but we treat the table as a
single object as if it were made out of
a single piece and you measure that
across and say you know the length of
the table is so-and-so in fact you'll
never see a mathematician you know
measure the table and then subtract all
the interstitial space and say oh by the
way you know I'm just gonna count the
matter now you look at it from one side
to the other but then what happens he
calls that also a distance because
essentially he measured from one point
to another whether you know you can
remove the table he said well I've got
the number the locations memorize in my
hand so I'm gonna measure space I mean
this point that a meters a meters a
meter and so they can say about the
length of a table is a meter or the
distance between here and there is a
meter and so for them it's the same
thing because they have to unroll the
tape one way or the other
yeah but then the question becomes where
could someone get tripped up if you
don't with that distinction with the
distance or there is a an issue in
general relativity where distance has a
different notion because they start
getting into geodesics and those are
curved distances where they call it a
straight line when it's not a straight
line and the question is is the distance
between the arrow and the feathers of
the arrows arrow head and arrow the
feathers of the arrow is
if the arrow is curved is the distance
there the same thing is the length of
the arrow so you get into situations
where these people have gone off you
know I mean they left
Euclid a long time ago you know and so
now they're inventing new math every day
and they come up with all these things
you've got riemann architectures you
know you have riemann triangles and
that's riemann putting it on the you
know what is it he puts the triangle on
his horse or no that was love with
Chesky love with Chesky put it on his
first created the saddle and and riemann
put it on his sphere and he created a
curve you know curved triangle and and
they keep calling it a triangle and you
say well hold it Franco has so much
length by it sizes it will not really
because see now the angles change
because now you have curvature well
that's not a triangle a triangle is what
you could define which is a flat you
know it's belong to the world of the
plains not to the three dimension but
now they've invented three dimensional
planes triangles and you have you put
the square there I guess the squares
gonna distort as well anything you put
in there well the sense you can say
there's no such thing as a curved
triangle yeah triangle by definition you
don't have a curve anywhere in there and
what they do is they try to calculate
angles on curved surfaces and they can
get into all this weird thing that has
little to do with science are with or
with physics and you know they've
developed a lot of that and then these
words become important at some point
where you say well what's that distance
or was that length
you know Rd measuring the distance from
one point in the triangle to the other
through a curve through some kind of
geodesic or are they measuring a
straight line which you know in one case
it would be the length of that curve in
the other the distance would be straight
across and now you have a little bow and
whether you measure the bow or the
string is a little different and so this
is you get into situations of that
nature you got to be careful because now
language plays an important role at that
point that's what I'm worried about you
know so that's why we should keep on
saying yeah yeah I mean it's best to
keep our language as precise as possible
just in case yeah yeah
but you say a lot what is physics and
what isn't physics so the question
becomes what does physics concern itself
with and what doesn't it I'm saying that
physics and that's the branch of science
in other words let's start with science
science rational explanations right we
have a definite generation we have
definition for explanations that differs
from descriptions and narratives ok so
now we go into physics physics is one
branch of science and philosophy I say
is the other one one deals with objects
causes and mechanism the other one deals
with concepts reasons and purpose ok so
now we haven't separated we say ok this
is this is a this over there and this is
this over here we get a black and white
situation we can all understand we can
all follow this we can use these words
consistently so what is physics do well
physics is the branch of science that
does rational explanations we carry that
forward but now it does rational
explanations only in the realm of
objects of mechanisms of causes so what
do we look at we say well what caused
this result or what caused this event to
happen in such a way and now we study it
and again when we do explanations very
important we always look at the past we
look at consummated events that's also
and so now we try to explain it that if
we're talking about for example if I
wanted to build a car uh-huh now it's
for the future now I'm not doing physics
if I ask the question hey how do I build
a car that's not know first that's
technology but assuming you did not
let's assume you you were not talking
about that but you're saying for example
there will be an eclipse tomorrow two
o'clock or no right the general question
is how do I do something any of the I do
in the future and that's not physics in
other words that's not science it's
outside the realm of science if it's a
and again I want to distinguish between
making something I'll call that
technology invention there's nothing
making can just be like how do I push
another car or how do I push the cart or
something right anyhow question of
future of future yeah not how did
something happen that's a different
question right but how do i XYZ how do i
how do i jump rope that's a recipe
that's that's a recipe yeah it's not
part of science science even though it's
qualitative you know because you can say
okay just wing the rope around yourself
it's a recipe it's a procedure it's a
specification you can even write a spec
I mean I wrote tons of Specht you write
a spec and say this the way I want you
to run the machine you know interesting
yeah but that's not science recipe is
false at a science right you how to make
a cake how to make a cake or whatever
no no but you can have one even in the
literal sense in their cooking you know
since that is where it's usually used
you say look this is how you make a cake
or this is how you cook fish or whatever
that's not science but they're
scientists how did you cook the fish
talking about the rules of science is
not science because that's also a recipe
when we talk about what are the what are
the rules to stay within science or the
laws of this debate how do how should we
conduct ourselves yeah those are rules
oh that's not a scientific I mean the
chart that you pull up yeah essentially
using science the church is not science
I'd say that it's a recipe I think that
for any science or not okay for any
specialty you know and I'll follow this
up as well for any discipline and we're
calling science the number one
discipline though the bottom discipline
you need some foundations that's what
I'm saying okay you need foundations for
example for physics for physics you need
to have certain foundations you need to
define the word object for example you
can't do physics without objects so
that's a principle an inviolable
principle you you know it's
non-negotiable you must have a physical
object and if you're if you don't have a
physical object you're not gonna be
doing physics yeah yeah no but what I'm
referring to is the following yeah it is
a recipe it's a specification but what
I'm saying is in to start out you know
in any discipline whether you go to
architecture whether you go to
archaeology or whatever you need some
found
nations like you know what is our
discipline amount yeah rules but it's
like what is our discipline how are we
know how how are we gonna know that
we're within our discipline within your
job right that we don't have some
foundation so it's a minimum I think you
need for any like someone asked me also
about the philosophy rational philosophy
you know and all I can do is propose
because you know I don't deal with
philosophy I don't care too much about
that but you know I propose that first
of all define the terms you and in fact
I tried to define these terms here let
me just put that up for a second here
it's uh where was it here this one
[Music]
causes physical source of phenomenon of
a phenomenon event or effect mechanism a
movie of a physical interpretation
purpose the deliberate result these art
of an action reason a premeditated
thought process that results in action
reason and purpose is probably synonym
said they're just I just kind of
reworded them in different ways but I
think you need these if you want to do
philosophy in other words you need
purpose and reason defined and that's as
a minimum that I can say the other one
is you need to define what a concept is
which I've also done I'm saying it's a a
concept is a word that evokes two
objects so there's a relationship
relation performed by a conscious
observer between two objects and that's
gonna be what we call a concept and I
think there are no as far as I can tell
there are no concepts that I know of
that violate what I just said and you
look for a universal you need for
something that you you know encompasses
all concepts looks just like object but
is an object that which has shape there
is no object that does not have shape
and so that's the universal that's
that's the common denominator and and
what I'm saying is you need to include
these foundations for any discipline
whether you're new philosophy history
whatever you do you need to have some
foundation so that you know you're
within the discipline to clarify that
that's not science we're talking about
itself no
because it's a specification on the
recipe we won't go anything a process
now we got three different types of what
he called utterances we got
prescriptions or recipes yeah we got
rules okay we're talking about now yeah
we got explanations prescriptions and
rules are not science but explanations
are science yeah not sure if we would
put them all or compare them in that way
I'm saying prescription because there's
different types of utterances there's
different types yeah
reasons for things things that like
categories for speech uh-huh we're I
guess what we're talking about are the
purposes of speech that's how you can
categorize different types of speech
there's you know speech for rules we
need we need rules to figure in you know
the category of rules has its purpose a
category of prescriptions and recipes
have has its purpose and the category of
explanations
that's where science is the essential
branch that's that's the foundation of
science but let me just clarify about
this yeah let me clarify one thing there
and that's that you know recipe what was
the other word recipe recipe rules and
rules specification that's the word I
wanted specifications those deal with
the future so so you're gonna be doing
science right and and right now I have
not explained anything I'm saying is if
you're gonna do science you're gonna
make a presentation on science again the
debate science okay these are the things
you must follow these are the
specification the recipe of course that
in itself is not science those are just
a prescription that's all it is a recipe
and the other person might say well you
know I don't like your your recipe I
don't like your prescription and so
before you go into the conference rooms
to talk about science you got to fight
that out in the ring you got a debate
that first because otherwise you know
it's meaningless to even style we're
talking about the behavior
to do science not science itself right
and and this is one of the problems I
see typically when atheists and theists
debate you know they haven't established
the rules of what science is that's what
they should be discussed you know they
go directly into God well does God exist
no the Bible says there's the other guy
said yeah but look at all the evil in
the world so they get into the debate
and they never defined what what their
debate in other words the rules of
engagement yeah what they had to set up
first is look what is science what is
route let's separate science from
religion that one we can talk
intelligently then we can use these
words intelligent that is the right way
but I mean my point here is that unless
you take that first step and and define
science and religion separate them
somehow so it's a black and white issue
because the other guy says well you know
God and whatever and this guy said well
that's not science that's religion and
this guy's trying to say no that is
science because you know God runs the
world and so on yes no no but unless and
yeah I know but what I'm saying unless
you define these terms rigorously and
say look this is what we're gonna call
religion this is what we're gonna call
science unless you separate those then
we're gonna have all this gray area
where people say well no you're not a
scientist you're a religious idiot and a
guy or a look at what you believe in you
know and and so you're also religious
and so they never define what religion
and science is that's why they get into
these eternally but circularly fades
really that's that's why this science
only Neil with the past well because
with explanations information you can
only come science behind the futuristic
yeah and that's that's wholly misleading
I'm saying and again this is my proposal
remember keep that in mind this is you
know Bill Gates proposing this you can
say Billy you're full of [ __ ] okay fine
but this what I'm proposing is not
what's out there and what I'm saying is
you know science deals with explanations
explain you can only explain a
consummated event science does not deal
with predictions and
somewhere that's in the mathematicians
because they like it hold it let me
finish they like it why because with
math they can say oh I know tomorrow is
gonna there's gonna be an eclipse at 3
o'clock in the afternoon use yeah and so
now they say I can predict I have the
power to predict right and this is where
the problem comes in because these
people you know with their equations
they want to predict they want to talk
about the future they also do the past
like they call it a prediction they say
well let me tell you let me I'm gonna
predict the original conditions of the
Big Bang that's 13.7 billion years ago
and the guy's got to predict the past
you know he's gonna create the initial
conditions of you know the Big Bang and
and so then the word prediction even
loses its meaning so you know again you
got to define these terms very precisely
and if you're gonna talk about
predictions about what's gonna happen in
the future even though it's a it's a
mathematically correct prediction in the
sense that you know this rocket is going
a certain speed and I can predict that
in two hours it's gonna be over here
right let's assume that's and then you
verify it and all comes out true right
it doesn't matter that's not science we
don't care about because that's just a
description or in this case I've we said
narrative the guys saying look this
these are the steps that I'm gonna
follow on this rocket and this rocket is
gonna be over here in two hours or
whatever there's the domino right and
again that's got nothing to do with
science science is how did the magician
do the trick that's yeah an explanation
I think with that you can answer that
question when I say why does the science
only deal with the past
well it's only deals of explanations who
can't really explain the future yeah
yeah that's weird to even say explain
tomorrow or you know explain maybe if
it's what if someone says explain why
why do why am I going to work tomorrow
no no no because that's a question of
purpose and I can do it
only after you went to work and say I
can tell you why you came to work late
or early today you came because you were
thinking about you know the ball game on
Saturday you know that's a theory so I
can explain why you came late to work
but I can't say tomorrow
I predict you're gonna arrive late
because you're thinking of the ball game
or something like Halley's Comet okay
yeah how do you explain that it's gonna
come tomorrow it's go you're never smart
you're not explained you're predicting
but but okay so it doesn't just fall
under the area of we don't know if it
really will like for all we know it blew
up some right sorry that's why rats
that's why the prediction no one can
predict that's why we say knowledge and
I say now this is a is a prediction now
this means that you can predict without
error that Halley's Comet is gonna come
but nobody can do that because you know
you don't know you know we're waiting
for a least common we can't see if we
say oh but I predict because I
calculated you're of it and I know it's
gonna come in in two hours you know and
it turns out Halley's Comet never
returns because it was blown up by an
asteroid who knows when that will
crashed against Pluto to take the other
side of that we could basically take a
prediction that's impossible like that
God can't live something again can you
explain why Albert Einstein will come
through the door tomorrow yeah but you
guys nothing you cannot talk about
explanation again in that sense because
it's not an explanation
I don't we use the term okay you sir
it's impossible right I'm thinking and
Halley's Comet okay no we can't all in
the back of our mind okay it's gonna
happen yeah yeah but if we take it no no
but it's wrong nobody again it's an
irrational it's an irrational statement
or a question because you're using
explain in a futuristic it's like it
ain't nothing when I Stein coming
through the door it's clear or why you
can't explain the future
okay that's what your sessoms yeah the
only way nobody ain't coming through the
door tomorrow is like okay that's not
gonna happen so what do you mean we
can't explain that
yeah you can't explain it only in the in
the following sense and that's where the
mathematicians do and that's through the
block universe if everything has already
happened everything is already past
tense but from here on til the end of
time
whatever you let's assume the universe
collapses at the end of time and
the big crunch let's assume that's the
end of the universe okay so until then
we have this block universe then
everything that happened everything that
happens already happened in a way and
we're just stepping on footprints okay
they were just you know we're not
creating any any new roads or anything
the road is already there for us to walk
on in that case everything is an
explanation but but you know us poor
humans you know we don't have the
capabilities of God to see the end of
the block universe so all we can say is
that you know first yeah let it happen
before we explain it we cannot say that
the future has already happened that's
the first one because you know there's
no there's no way we can show that it's
already happened that's just you know a
thought a concept someone invented that
the universe already exists with all its
events in the future
that's one thing the other one is that
well assuming they did assuming the
block universe is there for us to walk
on we still don't have the understanding
to know what's gonna happen tomorrow you
know if God already knows that's fine he
knows but we don't know is so we cannot
say look I know that I'm gonna walk
tomorrow to the park because I don't
know that you know so again we have to
eat it for our sake for for discussion
among humans
not with gods you know when I go to
Mount Olympus I'll talk differently with
Zeus but now that I'm here on earth and
I want to talk to you I gotta talk
intelligent me so that you understand me
and I can't say you know oh I know that
you're gonna go to the ball game
tomorrow
no because maybe a car runs over you and
you're dead why I didn't know that I
didn't know that was gonna happen
you know so he never made it to the ball
game my prediction did not come true so
again we don't know we don't know we
cannot predict without error because we
don't know we don't know what's gonna
happen we talked a lot about time right
well I don't you say the past
consummated events quality of time yeah
yeah do you think time confuses a lot of
debates or even conversation is just in
general even to oneself monologues
for you somebody in physics you think
time is just just like like a monkey
wrench any time someone invokes time it
confuses the issue more than it recall
it enlightens well quantitative time
certainly confuses lots of people
because no-one's ever defined what what
time is now I define time as a
relationship between two motions two
objects moving you relate one to the
other again requires an observer second
it requires a relation but this time
we're not comparing two locations which
is what motion is but we're comparing
two motions it sounds like a medical
minute because if concept no a is motion
if you're comparing motions because the
motion is essentially a comparison
between two locations right yeah I'd be
a motion but then now minimal meta
motion or a comparison between Botox
which is weird comparison of two motions
but but this is the point that I'm
dragging I'm saying that you know we
don't need that why do we need to
compare two motions as far as you know
before and after in that sense right
yesterday and today yesterday and
tomorrow decades ago versus centuries
ago do we need any of that well you know
I I don't see why we need it for an
explanation we might in some instance I
don't know but we don't need a regular
basis to explain the physical world
around us which is what we're trying to
do with physics we're address say you
know how does a magnet work I do I need
time for that now
do I need time to know why I fall to the
earth why parachutist falls to the earth
instead of you know going to the moon
I know well yeah time I don't need time
in a series of frames in that sense yeah
you could say that you need time but you
don't need time it's just that it's a
fact that you know if you've got the
movie in front of you and again the
movie has to be seen sideways the frames
are not visible like this they're
visible like one right after another
like you know
you lead into nice baseball cards right
you got them or any kind of stack of
cards you know there are sideways okay
that's the first one but the point here
is that you know time is is is a concept
that we do not need to explain something
but it is obviously taken for grandeur
embodied in your explanation because you
say look if I'm gonna show you a movie
and you know but what is a movie what
are you showing me you're showing me a
comparison of frames and there's a
motion between the objects inside the
frame so you do have time in there yeah
of course there is but it's like we
don't need I don't need to include time
and specifically state look I can't
explain this without time no it's
embodied in your explanation but you
don't need to invoke time and say look
yesterday I'm gonna explain something
where yesterday versus today is
important you know I can't see that I
can't see where we need to in both
qualitative or quantitative time to
explain any that's one of those yeah
it's it's there it's like motion motion
is also included in there you don't have
to bring in motion specifically or a
rate and say Oh velocity three meters
per second or whatever I don't need to
book that in there imply that something
is a motion period you know and I don't
need to say look I'm gonna invoke before
and after in terms of motion this guy's
was over here now he's over he's got
different location it's it's it's
implied in the movie itself there is a a
movie that's what's called a movie or a
motion picture right so motion is
involved here but I don't need to
specifically invoke motion to explain
something you know earlier you said you
kind of classify time as a relationship
between two motions yeah and a
relationship obviously implies doer or a
later yeah you need to crunch in there
you need memory yeah yeah so does that
mean that time is subjective yeah of
crazy by default there's no such thing
as objective time that's what Einstein
proved with relativity in a sense he was
right you know
time and again it's got to do with the
velocity of light if light remains
a constant and what's got a very or what
has to give is time and so that's how he
came up with these notions that time
well no no no but it's important for the
question you had and listen listen what
I'm saying in the equation you know he's
got an equation there and he fixes the
velocity realize is this this is
non-negotiable you can't change the
speed of light even though they do in
refractive index let's forget about that
for a second but he puts little C
300,000 kilometers per second and he
keeps it as a constant okay so what has
to give well what has to give his time
one has to give his mass what has to
give his length the other parameter so
that's the one that stretches and
shrinks and that's how he creates all
these fancy little concepts that you
know you can your brother is your twin
brothers 50 years older or younger than
you you know he comes up with all this
stuff why because he fixes the velocity
of light so in these equations he has to
give something in time is what gives so
so in that sense yeah and he says look
time is not the same for all observers
okay right and you know it's like oh
you're coming at it from different yeah
yeah in the sense that if you need to
really have a relation between two
motions you need someone relating those
motions like I could be drunk okay could
be I don't forget about drunk in fact it
could be objective but look at his his
perspective he's the gantt to objects
let's say there's two asteroids right
and once moving at a certain speed the
other ones moving in another speed and
I'm looking here from a given angle 45
degrees so I see these two things I say
oh man this one's going so fast and
there's so much distance between them
this one you know I can make an analysis
what about the the Klingon what about
the Martian the Martian over there he
sees it from a different angle he says
oh look each other I've got a different
conclusion because of his what they call
you know the frame of reference writing
a good good thing for time and that's
essentially what Einstein said Lawson is
trickier like when you're on a train and
the thing close to you go faster and
things in the back yeah sometimes you
don't even wear trainers movie the
trains move at the same time but one is
moving slower or even
Sonia on movie you say Oh am i moving
you know and maybe you are moving but
slower than the other guy the guy goes
you know faster you started earlier than
you didn't so you're moving you suddenly
you look out the window so who's moving
yeah you know and again and motion in
that sense and time in that sense our
you know relative is the last question
but it's not a biggie for physics it's
not it's it's a non-issue massive gnosis
we're all under well remember I include
not only comparison to motions but that
implies and I do clarify that you
absolutely need memory to conceptualize
time you need memory you need a
recording device it could be your brain
could be a record or I don't care but
time requires memory you have to compare
the motion of object a versus the
control you know the target object
versus the control object you need to
compare and for this you need memory
because you got to remember the motion
of one end the motion of another only
then can you can you conceptualize time
so time absolutely requires memory I
think no one has figured it out in your
honor here is there I mean there must be
a lot of thoughts are memory lost people
who can't keep track of time right right
for them for sure for sure there is time
dilation okay folks we'll see you on
Sunday hopefully today's uh sound came
out a little better just in case yeah we
had an international call in the middle
of our talk yesterday I think that's
what caused the blurb in the background
noise but it's more to congratulate us
on our yeah so so we think we figured
out what the problem was and hopefully
today came out a little better well see
you on Sunday and same time same station
to you that bye-bye